um all right so for people who don't
know um I recently it's funny cuz I had
Yola on Y and uh we had been following
each other for a while and I had one of
my friends go on this podcast and I kind
of like dived in and I'm like I've been
kind of
oblivious to the YouTube space yep for a
while I recently got hip to it in the
last like four or five months and I'm
like oh there's like this
whole it's a whole like it's kind of
crazy cuz you know when I think of
YouTube like being on even like my side
of like the Creator space like man I get
flat we get yellow videos so much I
wouldn't even think that there's like
that and um and then I found out about
you cuz I saw on on Yola's page you've
been on there three or four times I
think five at this point Jesus um so I
watched one of your interviews MH and um
I was like oh this kid's cool as thank
you I appreciate that for people who
don't know you kind of came onto the
scene playing video games while doing
and reviewing off camera pretty much
yeah that was my uh my initial way that
I got a following at least when I was
long a lot younger I was a degenerate
you know I was I was big into getting
high on whatever the I could afford for
the day you know so um I I kind of came
up just doing like mixing my my gaming
stuff with my stuff so so that was kind
of what put you on the map um yeah so
you growing up like what was your
childhood like like what was your house
like you know like um I mean my I had a
pretty good childhood you know my my
parents divorced when I was super young
so it wasn't something that really
bothered me cuz I just got used to it
they divorced when I was like three you
know you know yeah it was like hell yeah
two Christmases hell yeah you know mom's
fighting dad who's buying the better
gift you know I love that so um you know
growing up my childhood was pretty good
um as I got a little older got into like
middle school high school I kind of just
started like being a little delinquent
you know going to the store stealing
around at school um and it I don't
really know like what drove it I think
it was either like I got ADHD have a
hard time focusing need to do like a lot
of impulsive to keep me going um or
maybe I was just bored I don't know but
um so you just kind of like were out of
boredom you were just around getting in
like small trouble as Aid yeah you know
I I Wasing around nothing really major I
would bad grades in school you know that
type of thing um and then once I got
into high school and I started meeting
all these new people and like going to
you know parties and like social events
and you know you go to homecoming
drinking liquor in the parking lot type
you know um that's when I really got
introduced to the stuff that a lot of
people now know me for you know and and
see me uh you know make videos about was
it we initially um I drank first but
after that yeah was my first thing that
I really picked up like damn this is it
you know this is amazing uhuh I um my
first time smoking I remember I was 15
and me and my friends we went to this
little Forest Preserve and we had rolled
this blunt and it was a swisser some
like garbage I don't know what the hell
we put in it but you know 15-year-old
kids not smoking anything good right so
we um we hopped out at the Forest
Reserve and we were walking around and
my first time I didn't really get very
high you know I I didn't get what all
the hype was about I was like damn this
is it you know like this sucks and then
a couple days later I hung out with the
same dudes again and they were like yo
just try it again go for it you know
second time greatest night of my life
like I will never forget that night um I
it was like it was just I had been drunk
before you know but this was something
different and I was like damn and and it
was kind of weird cuz like I'd never I'd
never felt anything like that before you
know so I was yeah the first time you
get like smacked for real really stoned
you're
like man mhm yeah you're just sitting
there different cuz it is way different
than getting drunk yep yep 100% 100% I I
think I think most people like you know
I think I don't know if like you CU I
mean look you're always you're going to
get higher than the first time you've
been smacked if you keep smoking but I
think just like that first time I just
remember the first time I got like super
high mhm I got super paranoid like I I
it had to be sativa was at a party dude
and I just started I had like the
freakout High which is like the you see
in the movies yeah I feel you before I
had like the just I'm out bro like you
know but yeah the Freak Out high is a
yeah's not fun not fun at all man heart
starts racing you're sitting there
you're like am I breathing enough or no
like so for you you start smoking in
high school yep yeah I was 15 I started
smoking um my grades were already bad
going into that were already they were
all yeah I uh my junior year of high
school I finished my GPA was 0.8 oh yeah
I had below one so they kicked my ass
out of school and sent me to the
alternative school oh love those
alternative schools with the pregnant
chicks yeah oh so dude so chicks with
babysitters my alternative school had
less than a 100 kids in it whole school
um and out of that maybe five of them
were girls three of them were pregnant
like on rotation any given moment you
know it it was it was a trip but one
time got sent there is really where you
know my my use and all that kind of
opened up cuz all those kids are with
the [__] for real yeah yeah you know
going into it I was like oh this is
probably just other kids who like don't
really care and then I got there and I'm
like oh these kids are taking for
breakfast and like okay I see you know
first period like before class starts
they're smoking blunts in the stall you
know like okay different type of
schooling super different it's crazy cuz
when I was uh in high school I'm
probably older than you I'm 36 mhm so
when I was in high school like uh were
popping so people would like crush up
and
sniff this was before hands were like a
thing like yeah it was it was it
was and it was and then the Mormon kids
would do
hair dude I don't know what it is about
the Mormon kids from where I'm from
shout out to Mesa these kids always were
getting the girls were getting [__] in
the ass cuz it was their hole to not
break theg the holy loophole the holy
loophole and the and everybody else's
all the kids who parted that were Mormon
were shooting it the wildest [__] ever
yeah I um you know it's kind of funny my
uh my high school's like big Choice
they're always like on the local news
for ODS because I grew up in like a
pretty nice area with a lot of like just
Christian kids and you know it's always
those kids yes it's the super religious
kids that go hard as hell they want to
be like your [__] the parents yeah
they've been holding it in for like you
know 15 20 however long years you know
they're ready to blow in more than one
way more than one way so did you start
you go from you're 15 uh you go to the
alternative schools that restart diblin
and dablin with some of the more
hardcore yeah you know prior to getting
to that school you know I tried a couple
things I'd done the Zan you know I tried
like getting cough meds you know I was
so you were sipping some lean no no not
the lean like going to Walgreens
stealing nightquil yeah yeah I mean I
didn't have the money for lean dude I'm
let try some nil yeah we're going to
Walgreens we're hitting the Shelf sever
cold and flu yep yep you ever heard of a
triple C's I I feel like I've heard of
that the carissan coughing cold pills
those little bad boys yep yeah I think I
took one like three months ago when they
still make those and I can't believe it
I can't believe it you used to take
those and just get all the time yeah I
remember the first time I took them um
there's this kid named Andrew we all
called him mop and I went over to hang
out with him and he was like everyone
knew him as just eating boxes of these
things like yo catch Andrew early in the
day he's GNA be like face down you know
like eating this from the store yeah
yeah eating the Triple C's so he'd eat
like two boxes of these things it was 15
about he eat like 30 of these a day and
um what the I went over and my first
time I asked him I was like how many
should I take and he was like oh like 15
and I was like oh okay cuz I didn't
understand like dosages or anything yet
i' never done
no I was thank god dude I I was face
down on homie lawn for like 2 hours
middle of the summer it was like July I
was sweating andit um but yeah so I I
like went over there I asked him how
much to do he told me 15 took that
terrible ass experience but it was the
first alternative to weed and liquor
that I was introduced to so I was like
yeah I'm going to try it again like take
a little less and then I got real into
it and I was like yo I can bring this to
school and just like say I'm sick you
know yeah say have a C so I would I
throw the Triple C's in my bag like
every day I throw would you like put
them in your drink and let them dissolve
or no I just pop them you know just go
to the bathroom take like five or six of
them and then you would you just come
back to class and knock out on your arm
like see so the whole the whole point of
getting high off the DXM the cough meds
is you got to fight the sleep cuz that's
when the fun starts so it's like if you
fall asleep you lost you know so if you
if you go to sleep you miss out on the
fun part yeah you're missing it all you
know you're missing the the good and
cough meds they're like it's not even
fun really most like an awful like
poverty drug to do like it's really the
only people abusing meds are like kids
who have no money poverty you know so uh
I uh I just like I remember just loving
like fighting the the sleep and sitting
there in like second third period in
school and just being like yo I'm
feeling weird you know looking at the
wall and just like I got tracers
everywhere and like glowing a little bit